une relation pas très longtemps et Roger
au téléphone avec quelqu'un et je lui
dis bah je te passe mon ami et je vais
passer et je vais prendre une douche et
lui parler et quand je suis revenu il
m'a rendu le téléphone
et pendant 48 heures vous avez la gueule
ah ouais ce qui est pas à me dire qu'il
avait un ananas tu vois et ça a craqué
au dîner et il avait lu un SMS c'est
quoi le SMS
c'était un garçon
mais j'avais pas vu depuis des années et
elle est à l'époque il m'avait dit non
donc cette crème d'y fantasme dans la
tête et on s'était retrouvés dans un
restaurant et il m'avait envoyé
j'aimerais bien que tu viennes dîner et
éventuellement qu'on baise
et là tu lui as fait ma réponse tu sais
moi j'ai pas très fort